good morning and welcome to sophie ridge
on sunday
yes you're quite right a month ago i did
say i didn't expect to be back in this
seat but sophie's taking an easter break
so i'm off the subs bench as the danish
proverb goes prediction is a mugs game
especially when it comes to the future
four weeks ago in the face of russia's
brutal assault on ukraine few would have
predicted yesterday's astonishing
walkabout by vladimir zelinsky and boris
johnson in downtown kiev
here at home who saw the meltdown of
rishi sunak's political career coming
with hindsight making the rest of us pay
more tax while his wife elected to pay
less tax here
doesn't look like smart politics even if
it is perfectly legal
worse still the chancellor has some
questions to answer about his own
finances after sky's sam coats revealed
that mr sunak chose to retain his status
as a legal permanent resident of the
united states
long after he entered downing street
so
are we going to follow that danish
advice and avoid looking into the future
with our guests this morning
not a chance
[Music]
in just a moment for the government i'll
speak to the crime and policing minister
kit malthouse
and we'll get the view from labor with
the shadow home secretary yvette cooper
as ever it's crucial to hear from voices
on the ground in ukraine and this
morning we'll talk to the red cross's
chief of delegation to ukraine pascal
hunt
and the woman leading the effort to
gather evidence of war crimes and build
cases against those responsible
sadly she has much work to do the
prosecutor general of ukraine irina
bennett
cover much of the trouble the chancellor
finds himself in is how the focus on his
family's tax arrangements and wealth
looks when so many people in this
country are struggling sometimes because
of the decisions he takes so we'll speak
to helen barnard from the joseph
roundtree foundation about what is
calling the biggest fall in the value of
out-of-work benefits in half a century
[Music]
let's start with crime and policing
minister kit malthouse
good morning uh minister
morning trevor uh the prime minister's
um been in kiev talking to mr zelinski
and about providing more weapons what
has he promised and when can the
ukrainians expect delivery
well obviously we're uh funneling as
much assistance as we possibly can both
financial and military into ukraine as
quickly as we possibly can
yesterday obviously there were promises
of more equipment 120 armed vehicles
anti-ship missiles and that was on top
of another 100 million of general
equipment
but it's worth bearing in mind we've
also taken measures to assist
economically lifting tariffs on most
imports coming in from
ukraine and also adding another 500
million pound of million dollars sorry
of loan guarantee uh through the world
bank to assist ukraine in its economic
welfare as much as possible and that of
course is on top of us being one of the
biggest bilateral humanitarian donors
into the area we're pulling out all the
stops to try and help ukraine as much as
we possibly can the prime minister being
there on the street quite a remarkable
moment actually that walkabout even for
me who's followed the career of the
prime minister over many years as you
know um i think symbolize the support
and the leadership that we're trying to
show across the world as we
you know seek a victory for ukraine
we'll we'll come to the issues of
sanctions and so forth in a moment let's
just stick with the military situation
for the if you wouldn't mind um
this morning we're reading about what
looked like war crimes uh by the
russians what does the latest
intelligence tell us about what's
happening uh on on the ground please
well obviously there are um it's a fast
moving and difficult situation in which
the the kind of fog of war uh is is
makes the situation sometimes unclear as
far as we can see obviously uh ukraine
is resisting strongly uh the eruptions
are falling back in particular areas but
it did feel yesterday coming through
certainly on on some of the publicly
available information as if russian
forces were massing for an assault in
the east of the country we're watching
very carefully and doing what we can to
reinforce the ukrainian military
as much as possible to resist any
further attempts by russia to take their
country and to push them back where they
possibly can
so so the advice that you're getting
or the intelligence you're getting at
forgive me is essentially that if there
is uh if you like a retreat by the
russians it's in order to regroup
and to mount an assault on the east of
the country donbass and luhansk for
example
well trevor i obviously don't want to on
on screen here today uh give a sense of
what we think may happen it may be
happening and therefore may be second
guessed by the the russians say it's a
horrible situation ukrainians are
fighting bravely as the prime minister
said like lions we're doing what we can
to reinforce them and give them as much
weaponry as they possibly can including
anti-ship missiles now to defend
themselves um and if possible uh move
the russians off their uh territory this
is turning into a much longer conflict
than i think the russians calculated for
and much of that is down to the
fortitude and the courage of the
ukrainians
assisted we hope uh by the western
munitions that have been uh pouring into
that country defensive munitions
allowing them to defend their turf
but of course um i understand your point
about not wanting to
reveal uh the west military hand one of
the things that we are be becoming
pretty clearly aware of is that there
are war crimes being committed here
and allegedly
by russian
forces um
what exactly are we doing to guarantee
that those people are brought to justice
at some point
well obviously that's a matter for the
international criminal court and as you
will know the deputy prime minister
dominic rabb has been over
uh to the hague i think to talk the
international criminal court about what
support we can give them in the pursuit
of those
who've perpetrated what are quite
obviously war crimes uh during this
dreadful dreadful conflict um the
gathering of evidence during the
conflict obviously needs to be done as
assiduously as it possibly can given
that it's a conflict zone and then
following any um
outcome from the conflict that obviously
needs to be pursuit of those individuals
now while that is ongoing uh obviously
we can take action domestically around
sanctions that we're able to put on
individuals
including competence leading generals
and others uh they're involved in it to
signal ah if you like recognition of
their part in this dreadful dreadful
assault upon a free democratic country
but making sure that the icc is in a
good position to deal with this as soon
as they possibly can is where we need to
be
we understand that uh the metropolitan
police's war crimes unit is involved
here now uh you were yourself
responsible for the metropolitan police
uh for a while when you were at city
hall in london um
can you tell us what they're actually up
to there
well trevor i can't i'm afraid but they
are uh naturally engaged in gathering as
much evidence as they can to offer
assistance in the future if they
possibly can i mean that's an
operational matter for the police they
are operationally independent of me and
indeed of the government uh generally
but you can guarantee trevor that as we
are putting as much support into the
conflict as we possibly can to support
ukraine's in their fight we will do the
same to bring those to justice who
perpetrated some truly awful crimes
during this dreadful time
you have talked about the sanctions
we've imposed against mr putin's
oligarch friends we have stopped imports
we've thrown russian banks some russian
banks out of the international banking
messaging system swift
to be honest though it doesn't seem to
have
deterred him at all does it
well we shall see trevor as you know um
these sanctions
his troops are still there
yeah his troops are still there you are
quite right uh but as we seek to tighten
the sanctions net as we seek to
coordinate with our international
partners particularly in europe uh to
restrict uh the flow of money if you
like into russia particularly from their
uh gas and oil uh then that that ratchet
if you like starts to bite much more
often uh sanctions take a little bit of
time to feed through the financial
system
but where we can find
uh gaps in if you like in our army of
sanctions we are closing them as quickly
as we can as you know we legislated very
quickly to give ourselves the agility to
move to try and shut down as much of the
russian economy as we possibly can and
we'll continue to do that in the uh days
and weeks to come you know these uh
sanctions i think will start to bite if
they're not biting already very
significantly in russia and we hope that
that will give mr putin cause to reflect
well we i understand the point you're
making that we're trying to essentially
put a squeeze on the russian population
by uh preventing imports and so on but
the truth of the matter is
that mr putin's demonstrated he doesn't
care that much if his own people suffer
and as long as the germans continue to
buy his gas as long as the chinese
continue to trade and consume
consumer
goods and as long as india continues to
buy oil and
weapons from
russia
he's not that bothered shouldn't we
be focusing more frankly on our friends
than on uh some some of the things that
we're doing
look we're in constant conversation
treasure with all trevor with all our
allies across the world about what more
we can do
to build a really solid
barricade if you like against russian
economic activity across the world just
to say we have no dispute with the
russian people
this is a dispute with the russian
government led by mr putin who have
ordered this dreadful assault that's why
we've taken measures against these known
associates whether they be oligarchs or
others where we've taken measures
against uh members of the government who
strangely
forgive me for interrupting you but i
was really asking about our friends here
and we've heard actually from other
members of nato polls for example
uh and ukrainians themselves that
they're pretty disappointed with what
the germans are not doing do you think
any of our supposed allies and possible
friends are effectively letting down
this effort uh and putting a hole in the
barricade you just mentioned
well trevor look as i said we're
constantly talking to our friends uh in
germany and in france and elsewhere in
europe and in fact the president of
europe of the european commission as you
know visited uh kiev not very long ago
to express her support and the european
union has taken significant measures
having said that you know we do need to
bear in mind that uh you know
certain parts of europe are very
dependent on russian gas they are taking
steps now to wean themselves off the
germans in particular looking at what
more they can do to bolster their own
defense and of course nordstrom to that
pipeline which was due to come on stream
has been uh shut down or cancelled
we are pushing as much as we possibly
can for a strong set of sanctions from
the eu and the wider world as we
possibly can get we recognize that this
is a ratchet we need to turn as tightly
as we possibly can in the cause of
freedom in ukraine and we will support
the ukrainian president as he repeats
those calls across the world all right
before before we come back to domestic
politics what i do want to talk to you
about um
do you feel a bit ashamed that our
neighbors the
irish
reckon that they will welcome as many as
40 000
ukrainian refugees by the end of this
month while we have managed to admit 12
000
of the uh 70 or 80 000 who would like to
come here
well trevor you're right we've had about
just shy of 80 000 applications for
visas of those we've issued uh just over
40 000 and of that 40 000 you're right
12 000 have come to the uk now though
the the difference between the 40 000
and 12 um might be for a variety of
reasons we know that yeah but
it's it it's three times for three times
has a population a fraction of ours come
on
yeah no i completely understand and i
know that people are
uh disappointed uh with the progress of
the of the visa regime the home
secretary was out this week expressing
her frustration and regret that it
hasn't been quicker but we are motoring
now now it's worth saying that while we
issue visas to those individuals there
are a lot of people who are um in region
in poland and other countries who are in
receipt of uk visas uh but thinking
about their options preying upon hope
upon hope that they can return to their
country but in possession of the ability
to come to the uk for safe haven if they
wish now we are processing as fast as we
can we've now got hundreds of people
from across whitehall working on this i
think we did a thousand yesterday we
will accelerate during the week and we
hope to get that as fast as we possibly
can all right well i no doubt my
colleagues uh next time on this program
will will check up on that let's come
back to the cost of living here um
you didn't back off on the national
insurance rise uh don't need to explain
that again uh you published an energy
strategy this week with a lot of
promises about uh wind power and all the
rest of it for the medium term um but i
wonder if you could explain what any of
that is going to do for families who are
going to be faced with a big rise uh in
the autumn when the uh
cap goes uh rises uh in the context of
which
let's remember a quarter of british
families have no savings a third have
less than 100 pounds available to them
uh at at any one time how are those
people going to meet
that demand
for a rise in the cost of energy
so trevor look we obviously
we recognize that the rising the cost of
living and indeed fuel in particular is
very tough some of that comes from the
choices that we've made about supporting
ukraine some of it from a post-pandemic
kind of boom if you like it or
difficulty in in supply
we're doing what we can to try and
assist in that awful equation for so
many people by targeting as much
assistance as we can particularly those
who are on a lower income or low paid so
whether that's the warm home discount
going to three million people you know
the nine billion pounds uh energy rebate
scheme that we put in place there's lots
of support going in there and in
particular worth noting that we doubled
the household support fund now to a
billion pounds targeted at those who
will be really struggling and can go to
their local authority uh for assistance
it's worth it just on your on your first
question though trevor i i did let you
talk
i did i did let you
advance ukraine as an example but but
honestly
you put up the national insurance you
have not uprated benefits uh by more
than what 3.1 i think it is now against
an inflation uh rate now about 7.7
these are choices you are making
you are quite right these are choices
that we're making and we have to own so
we took a decision that the backlog in
the nhs required an investment of 39
billion pounds and that's what that
national insurance rise will raise but
remember trevor that the chancellor then
took the step of raising the threshold
which will come into effect later this
year meaning that 30 odd million people
will pay less national insurance as a
result don't forget also there is a if
you like a suite of tools that will
assist people who are low paid so the
national living wage rose i think last
friday by 6.6
um
we've also
increased the
taper on universal credit meaning that
those in work and in receipt of
universal credit will be better off by a
thousand pounds a year so when you look
at the overall package we are stretching
the financial envelope as much as we
possibly can to try and do two things
first of all to invest in those public
services particularly the national
health service but secondly assist those
people who are really struggling with
the cost of living as much as we can now
these are difficult choices all right
against the backdrop of a balance sheet
with a lot of borrowing on it coming out
of the pandemic and i understand that it
will be very very tough for lots of
people all right let's let's talk about
your principal decision maker on these
questions the chancellor um
i wonder if he's listening to the many
people in this country who are furious
that uh at the revelation
that um
he's raising taxes
while his wife made a choice
to pay tax not to the country that uh
her husband's asked to make these
sacrifices not to the country that puts
a roof over her head but to india now i
know it's not it's legal and all that
you don't need to explain that to me but
politically just a terrible mistake
massive tenure here
well first of all it's worth pointing
out that um
as miss murthy said she paid uk tax on
all her uk income
but you will have seen her statement she
accepted that um
there was a sense of disquiet about the
situation and she's moved to
uh correct it now she is a non-competent
in the political fray
but i think both she and rishi have
recognized that that situation was not
one that was favorable and it was
distracting from the overall message um
you know he's put a huge amount of
effort time commitment and energy into
helping this country get through the
last couple of years um and it's
unfortunate that his wife has been drawn
into this political fray in this way
they've now corrected that situation um
hopefully we can move on
well uh we can't quite move on because
uh it's not just her it's him uh we now
discover uh courtesy of my colleague
here sam coats that um for the first 18
months
as chancellor he held a green card which
you will know means legal permanent
resident of the united states uh
essentially
you know this also that uh that means
the united states expects uh him to pay
taxes on whatever he earned
in the whole world to them first now
not good is it i mean this is really
uh in the time when we want the whole
country to trust government and support
what it's trying to do
it's pretty
it's not a good look is it
well look rishi sunak was obviously
somebody who it's careless at least well
got himself a place overseas at stanford
got a job there and required a green
card as a result my understanding years
ago
yeah but my understanding was trevor
that this was a hangover from that time
um and that very often uh people with
green cards who don't go to the united
states don't take advantage of it it
just lapses and gets removed now you
know he obviously yeah but he's not come
on come on minister he's not just
anybody he's the chancellor of the
united kingdom
i
understand the intricacies of the
of the green card system but as far as i
could see and as far as i understand it
actually added more complexity and more
onerous obligations to him not less and
it certainly didn't impact on his tax
position in the uk where he was paying
tax uh but look he may be worth you in
the future getting him on to talk about
that stuff as far as i could see he took
advice from the american uh officials he
handed his green card back when he was
there and regularized that position as
well
but politically
he's toast isn't he
no i don't believe he is he yorishi
sunak is has been a remarkable force for
good in this country over the last two
years he put in place some incredible
support schemes during the pandemic at
ex enormous speed you know he managed to
produce a budget within just weeks of
becoming chesler he is a smart clever
committed politician um who has you came
into parliament with me and i've been
deeply impressed by him ever since
okay mr mulhouse i'm i'm sure that uh mr
sunny will be glad to hear your reply as
he consumes his own toast rather than
being it thank you so much for your time
i'm a big fan thanks trevor bye
all right now let's get labour's take on
things this morning from shadow home
secretary yvette cooper good morning
shadow home secretary
good morning trevor
now last week on this program
your colleague jonathan reynolds said
that sanctions on russia have had a
significant effect um
oddly enough the ruble is now worth more
than it was before the invasion
do you think that we need to do more
than is currently being
proposed by government we just heard
from kit malthouse
we do support stronger action we support
the action that the government has taken
to provide military support for ukraine
to be able to defend itself and to
continue to do so and we also support
strong sanctions and we think we need to
be continually looking at where further
we can go to put maximum economic
pressure on russia and on putin's
government that includes looking at
individual sanctions that also includes
looking more widely but we also need to
do this in a united way across not just
europe but across the world because i
think it's been that united front that
has been really important in addressing
this
really cruel and vile illegal war from
putin
are you worried that the united front is
essentially being punctured a bit by the
german reluctance to
stop gas we understand how difficult it
is for them but
it's not as difficult as it is for the
ukrainian people is it
obviously it's hugely difficult for the
ukrainian people and they have shown
incredible bravery in the response uh to
this illegal invasion as well and also
in response to war crimes that are
taking place in the terrible bombardment
so that's why we do yes urge germany and
other countries to really all work
together to try and reduce that
dependency on
russian oil and gas and to actually have
alternatives because this is obviously a
part of a broader sanctions approach we
have to have the strongest possible
action to put the pressure on
there are things that we can do
ourselves and i want to come to the um
issue of refugees in a moment which is
your uh
uh portfolio
but on the question of weapons um prime
minister's offering
more a fresh delivery of weapons to the
to ukraine
yesterday um do you think that we are
doing enough on the military and uh the
weapons end of things
well we support the action the
government's taken on this and i think
this is an important area as you say
there are huge differences between us
and the government on the support for
refugees where we don't think the
government's gone far enough but we
actually support the government on the
action that they've taken to provide
military support for ukraine and it's
good i think that we've got that
cross-party agreement on that and we're
going to have to continue to do so
because this doesn't look like this is
coming to a quick end
it's important that some of russia's
objectives have been frustrated by the
bravery of what ukraine has been doing
but we also know that they are
continuing this really horrendous
bombardment and we've seen obviously the
cases of torture as well
but i think the the issue around the
refugee visas is really important it is
shocking it is just truly shameful the
long delays that we have in getting
ukrainian families visas to come stay
with british families who want to host
and support them 30 000 people are
waiting for visas around half of them
have been waiting for more than 10 days
many of them have been waiting for two
for three weeks now
and having filled in all of the forms
this is just disgraceful delays and i do
not understand why prissy patel is so
failing to get a grip on this
well uh whatever they're doing one
simple way of cutting through this would
simply be to drop the visa requirement
as has been the case in uh countries on
the continent would labor support the
removal of the visa requirement uh for
ukrainian uh asylum seekers essentially
we think you should drop the extra
bureaucracy you can simply do so i'm
asking specifically about the visa
requirement
yeah
so
so we described a kind of emergency visa
which is effectively just the security
checks that's what we need to do you
don't need a lot of this additional visa
requirements for example to come on the
homes for ukraine scheme ukrainian
families are supposed to prove their
residence as to where they were living
before the 1st of january so people are
uploading utility bills or other kinds
of details that then has to be checked
by caseworkers that then adds to delays
the point about security checks is
ministers and officials have themselves
admitted you can do them on the spot you
can do them within a matter of hours so
there is absolutely no excuse for these
weeks of delays we should be able to
just do this and grant people permission
to come pretty much instantly and get
those checks done straight away
so to be clear
an emergency visa is still a visa but
you would only apply
one test
which you think could be passed within
hours about whether somebody's a
security risk or not
do you really think believe that yes
how would you know with the ministry how
would you know somebody says i'm not a
russian i'm not a member of the wagner
group i'm not coming to us how how would
we actually be able to know that within
hours
these are the standard security checks
that we already do um sort of standard
checks with with passports and so on and
ministers and officials have themselves
said they've themselves said that
security checks can be done online
they've themselves said these security
checks can be done either on the spot
you're effectively checking somebody
against a database of wanted criminals
you're you're checking people in that
respect so those are the kinds of checks
that you can do really quickly and
ministers and officials have both
admitted that they can do them really
quickly that's not what's holding things
up it's not the security checks it's the
fact that they've added huge amounts of
bureaucracy that they've never got a
grip of this and bear in mind the home
office had the opportunity to prepare
they had months to prepare for this it's
six weeks ago we were urging them to
take action and they haven't done so
pretty patel wanted to simply use the
existing visa system you remember we had
that awful moment when a home office
minister effectively was saying people
should get a seasonal workers visa
perhaps to come and pick fruit they
tried not to set up a proper scheme and
then when they did do so they added huge
amounts of bureaucracy to it but it's
letting everyone down you have disabled
disabled man for example who can't leave
ukraine until he's got his full visa in
a case that i know of you have moms and
kids who are running out of money and it
is shameful british people want to be
generous and want to provide support and
pretty patel is not letting them okay
forgive me for hiring you up but uh we
do need to talk about domestic politics
a bit one question uh or maybe a couple
questions on on this um
your former shadow chancellor john
mcdonnell said in
2019 uh in the manifesto actually that
you fought on that labour would scrap
non-dom status altogether uh is the
future labor government still going to
do that
well rachel's rachel reeves has set up a
review of all those sorts of tax
exemptions and tax arrangements and that
is underway at the moment but look there
is a clear issue at the moment which is
why you're asking the question about
rishi sunax household tax arrangements
at a time when he has been putting taxes
up for everyone asking everybody else to
pay over a thousand pounds more
his household has had special tax
arrangements that allow them to pay less
tax that is just unfair and that i think
is why people are so angry about what's
been happening and also the fact that
they've just not been transparent about
it when there could have been conflicts
of interest in place as well
well we all but um what everybody
acknowledges is that what she has done
is perfectly lawful uh as far as i
understand it lots of other people do
something similar and you might think
that you know it's ethical to do
something different but that she hasn't
actually done anything
wrong and i'm wondering whether labor
has the view
that this
perfectly lawful
status should now not be available to
people
well as i said rachel has a review
underway and we have previously proposed
reforms in exactly this area but the
issue now is that actually the ethics
matter if you are part of a household
where you are asking people across the
country to pay more to put taxes up to a
70-year high and everybody across the
country is really feeling the strength i
don't know how people are going to be
managing with the cost of living indeed
and
i think that is a serious problem i i
understand the point but it's quite
difficult to take the complaint
that she should have done something
different if you can't say that you
would make it unlawful
so i don't think that's right i think
that ethics do matter when you're in
government particularly there may be a
conflict of interest here as well so we
don't know for example whether the
chancellor declared a conflict of
interest when he was making decisions on
policies there's some policies reported
that do affect
non-doms people with non-dom status we
also don't know
what the facts are around some of the
reports about whether they've been
beneficiaries from tax havens and we
also don't know uh some of the wider
issues about why the chancellor has had
a permanent residence card in the u.s at
the same time as indeed parliament and
the member of indeed and i asked mr
mulhouse about that i'm interrupting you
simply because in order to make sure
that you don't have a conflict of
interest sorry i'm trevor sorry forgive
me i'm interrupting you because i know
that you want to talk about antisocial
behavior and i just wanted to give you
half a minute to to say uh labor's got a
policy out
today that to tackle
antisocial behavior by creating
police hubs and so on why not just more
police
we do think that we need more police and
particularly more police out on the beat
in our communities we had huge cuts to
police in which the government has
finally accepted it needs to start to
reverse although there are still fewer
police than there were in 2010 but even
now we're still not seeing the police
back in the neighborhoods it was one of
the most important policies labour had
was to set up neighborhood policing in
our communities to tackle anti-social
behavior we're at a time when crime has
gone up when prosecutions have gone down
and in many communities anti-social
behavior is right and isn't being dealt
with that's why we want to set up
neighborhood police hubs in communities
in towns right across the country to
bring together the police local council
officers to tackle that anti-social
behavior that is making people's lives a
misery and we pay for it by saying
cancel the royal yacht that neither the
navy nor the royal family want and use
that money to cut crime and anti-social
behavior i won't give you many more cops
that to that uh counseling the royal
yacht and and that's 200 million in one
year which has
i i've done some arithmetic it gives you
about
i think 60 police officers um in each
police force 43 each of 43 police forces
across england
so the royal yacht funding would fund
the hubs it would fund the centers for
example in castleford in my constituency
we now have we've persuaded the police
and the council to work together to set
up a hub there's another one redbridge
council have been setting them up which
are basically a base for local police
and councils to be officers to be based
in the community rather than to be based
miles away to be based locally in the
community and to work with the community
in hot spots of anti-social behavior and
to set up neighborhood prevention teams
what the conservatives have done is they
just collapsed any of the work on
anti-social behavior we used to have
loads of things going on they pulled
back from it they completely decimated
neighborhood policing we're saying bring
back neighborhood policing and bring
back the action on anti-social behavior
as well
yvette cooper thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you
it's now thought that more than 50
people were killed by a russian missile
attack on a train station in the east of
ukraine on friday as they try to escape
the fighting
the situation in the south and east of
the country is increasingly desperate as
russian forces focus on the area with
ukraine saying they're trying to destroy
civilians
the red cross again sought to reach the
besieged city of mariopol this week as
people try to flee
all as more atrocities are discovered
around kiev
now
pascal junt leads the international
committee of the red cross in ukraine
and join us now live from there
um
good morning uh mr hunt um
you're in western ukraine this morning
can you tell us uh anything about the
situation
for those who are fleeing the fighting
yeah good morning
yes indeed the situation for those
fleeing the fighting wherever it happens
it's an extremely difficult situation
fighting is taking place in densely
populated area
in cities
and these cities are being shelled and
we have seen the images we all these
images are really shocking even
outrageous
so you can imagine the level of despair
for these people
they're trying to leave
they wait for the train
they are being shelled so this is really
a dramatic situation
well you're referring to the uh
explosion
uh the missile attack frankly on the
railway station at kramertorsk what um
what are your people there telling you
about the aftermath of that
many uh consequences people are
even more in fear and despair this is
one of the problem
they do not dare to take the train
anymore so they are moving by car
they have difficulty to reach the the
hospital as well and as i speak the
international committee of the red cross
together with the german red cross we
also trying to facilitate the evacuation
of people wounded uh
in the front line so yes the situation
is is even more difficult for the people
they were trying to leave and and this
is becoming really difficult and we see
them moving more and more and taking the
private cars and moving by roads
oh so people there are now distrusting
uh rail as a mode of travel which
presumably must make
evacuation even more difficult and even
slower
i i don't know if they are distrusting
the the the railway but can you imagine
you are waiting in a railway station and
then the shelling is happening so they
are really afraid so what we have seen
is that some of them were moving by car
maybe they will try again to reach
another railway station and continue to
move by train but i confirm that people
continue to flee the area yes
you also have
teams uh who have been trying to get to
mario paul um can you tell us if any of
your people
actually made it there and whether or
not they made it uh what you understand
has happened there now
our team tried for five days
to go to mario paul
and it's a difficult journey because you
have to cross the front line you have to
go through many many checkpoints
sometimes the people at the checkpoint
and the soldiers they're not aware of
your or
of your trip
and it's just an illustration on how
difficult it gets to have translated
into action you know the agreement
between the capitals and how difficult
it is for the order to tickle down at
the checkpoint so we went there with
buses
we moved we try we try again and again
but unfortunately the situation around
mario paul was too dangerous the
security conditions were not good
the security guarantees we got were were
not good either so at around 20
kilometers from mario paul
we had to go back
we collected people on the road we
collected people in berlin
it was a long journey difficult journey
private cars were joining our convoy
under the flag of the red cross and
finally more than thousand people
reached zapurige
it may sound as a drop in the ocean
because the needs are much bigger the
situation is difficult there
people are there with no food no water
no heating system so yeah
it's really held there so i think many
more of such operation will need to take
place in in the coming days in the
coming weeks it is urgent
and we really uh are in contact with the
russian authorities with ukrainian
authorities to ensure that safe passage
is being provided to to these people so
they move they can move freely and
safely to to to much safer place
the red cross itself has come under some
criticism uh internationally and indeed
from ukrainian politicians uh themselves
in fact one spoke about it on this uh
program in previous weeks
uh saying that you hadn't done enough to
protect refugees
and uh that you were too close
to russia uh to do the job
that you're asked to do properly how do
you respond to that
i think it's a good illustration of the
difficulties
uh of being neutral there you know many
people understand the difficulty of
neutrality as of either you are with us
or you are against us and we have heard
that many years
and i think neutrality is more than
taking side and taking side of the
victims and doing everything
we can
in order to be close to the victims but
for doing so we need to discuss with the
parties to the conflict we need to
discuss with the ukrainian authorities
we need to discuss with the russians
ultimately they are responsible
of the behavior of the troops on the
ground they are responsible for
providing safety and security to the
population and they are responsible for
allowing humanitarian actors to go to
the front line to cross front line
we will continue to do so but it's a
complex endeavor and we are in
discussion with the parties on that
well there's no question about the the
icrc's
international reputation but you rightly
raise the issue of neutrality um
how is it possible to be neutral
when it is pretty clear
that one side
is committing
war crimes
and
seems ready to commit further war crimes
as long as neutrality is understood
as a mean to reach the victim as a
position of defending the victims and
being close to them
and
as a means to achieve
more protection and assistance
then
i think it is easier to understand that
and our neutral position
was
we have positive example of that it's
because of being neutral that we were
able to cross front line and to try to
go towards mario paul
it's because we are neutral that we can
go
to front lines and hot places
so
the meaningfulness of neutrality
is translating into
concrete outcome for the population and
we will continue to do that despite the
criticism
but i have to admit that the criticism
we faced with respect to not doing
enough or
to favor one side or the other
is also preventing us to work uh
it is undermining our mandate it is
undermining our access to people
and i hope that this will stop because
this is not helping us to to do our work
here
can you give an example of where that's
happened presumably you mean
that in some circumstances
uh trust is broken down presumably with
ukrainians uh uh in the
uh red cross and that's making it
difficult for you to
rescue survivors to provide uh medical
and other help
and this is not about the ukrainian
authorities with whom we are in contact
every day and they perfectly understand
our position it's more
difficult to understand for the public
for the diaspora
where basically they don't understand
that we have to discuss with the
russians
so it's a matter of us being better to
explain what we are doing
and also in being better in
showcasing what what we are doing on the
ground and to demonstrate that when
people are receiving aid and assistance
this is also due to the neutrality of
the red cross
all right then if i may just finally ask
you about we talked about mario paul um
and we've seen a lot of what's been
happening in the south but we've also
seen some
terrible
reports
of what has happened in the north around
kiev and for example in butcher
what is the icrc scene there
we have seen
the same image
as everyone
we have been in bucha in irpil in
norgamel yesterday we were in cherniv
north of the country
and we see
basically the same image everywhere and
this is truly appalling and
heartbreaking we are discussing with the
people there we find people in total
despair
with no food no electricity no water no
eating system they have to go out in the
streets to make some
fire
and cook you know i mean these people
were living in in
horrible conditions
so this is
the level of suffering that we are
seeing is just immense
and i don't recall having seen that in
recent history
we are collecting information we are
discussing with the people we do our
utmost to provide them with assistance
and whenever we see
problems uh
concern
then we discuss as well directly with
the ukrainians and with the russians on
that this is part of our bilateral
dialogue with the parties
to remind them of the
obligation under the geneva convention
and this is complementary to
the job that is done by
other groups that are coming vocal on
that journalists that are doing a good
job on the ground and we are
complementing this work
and we are discussing with the russians
on that as well
mr hunt thank you so much for talking to
us this morning
you're welcome thank you very much
now justice is a word we rightly hear a
lot now when it comes to ukraine justice
for the victims of the atrocities being
discovered bringing to justice those
carrying out
alleged war crimes
videos of bodies in bush
accounts of the killing of civilians are
prompting huge efforts to gather
evidence and build cases that will
hopefully hold those responsible to
account but it is a hugely challenging
and no doubt hugely affecting task
in ukraine that task is led by the
country's prosecutor general
irina benedictova she joins me now
live
good morning miss benedictova
good morning thank you that you are
having me
and i hope i've got the pronunciation of
your name correct um everything's good
it's it's russian surname sorry
sagan
it's russian surname sorry i am
ukrainian prosecutor general and i have
such complicated surname okay it's about
detoxification it's a very funny thing
about when russians speak about
denotification
okay uh i understand how important that
is to you anytime and especially now so
i'm good this morning going to address
you as an arena if you don't mind so i
don't get that wrong
um
what what can you tell us about the
situation that you are facing on the
ground in trying to
pursue and your task to build evidence
and so on
we have very brutal aggressive war
and actually what we see now in ukraine
it's still
fighting in eastern part of our country
absolutely brutal and aggressive
the nazi region lugansk region
harke region are under attack this night
and actually we understand that russian
troops again and again
started to
took our territory and started to take
through our territory and to kill our
people and we see this from day and day
you spoke with the chief of red cross
thank you very much for opportunity to
listen about key bridging for this
morning we have actually number uh only
for this morning 1000 two hundred twenty
two uh dead dead people in only in cave
region
uh of course what we
see on the ground in all regions of
ukraine
it's
war crimes crimes against humanity and
we
do everything to fix it
would you regard
knowing what we know about what happened
at the railway station at kramatorsk
is that a war crime
absolutely it's a war crimes it was a
russian missile
which killed more than 50 people these
people just wanted to save their life
they wanted to be evacuated with kids it
was women it was children and they just
wanted to save their lives
it was you have any evidence
that it was russian
yes we have evidence we understand um
a lot of connections times and so on
that's why it will be one of other cases
in
in our big profile you know that now we
started
5600 cases in ukraine only about war
crimes
um we have our anchor case from these
5600 cases uh oh two cases sorry
and we have our main anchor case where
we have
500 suspects it's a case about
aggression aggression crime aggression
russian federation against ukraine and
these 500 suspects it is the top
military stop politicians top propaganda
agents of russia federation who
who have done everything to started this
war and they continue this war in
ukraine does that 500 include uh
vladimir putin
vladimir putin is a main war criminal
of 21st century or we understand it but
from other side all of us
respect of international law which is
implemented in ukrainian
law
we know that three positions in national
jurisdictions have uh
functional immunity it is president
prime minister and ministry of foreign
affairs only this purpose because
they are still on their position they
are not suspects in our criminal case
but actually we understand when they
will not be on their positions or if
prosecutor of international criminal
court decided to prosecute them they
will be responsible for all their crimes
so if i understand this correctly
as long as mr putin remains president of
the russian federation he has some
immunity but the moment
he loses or relinquishes office
he will be
vulnerable to prosecution by you
absolutely international uh practice has
such examples that's why we understand
we
started all
practice of tribunals so
all possibilities and cases in
international humanitarian law the
practice of icg
um we see now very young practice of icc
that's why we understand different
strategies how to
punish
maine war criminals because actual when
dictators do and do again and again do
their aggressive very brutal worth in
our modern in civilized world it's not
normal it's uh we as the international
community should change maybe
instruments should change maybe
mechanisms and do everything not only
stop and punish we should to prevent
such
possibilities of
ordinary dictators
in the future
may i ask you you've talked about 5600
uh cases
can you tell us what the what is the
mechanism how first of all how do you
know about these cases and secondly then
how do you pursue them because we have a
history of course of war crimes taking
years even decades to be uh prosecuted
or and to bring people to justice
uh every every um
such case we have the facts
these five
5600 cases they're absolutely different
but by their size in one case it could
be only one fact of death civilians or
to destroy civilian infrastructure in
other cases it could be actually 10 or
100 episodes as what we see with these
our 500 suspects that's why they're
absolutely different by size but it's
impossible not to know about this almost
every region in ukraine
was bombed and we have a lot of
concrete facts in every uh region in
every city you mentioned with your
previous guest about mario park case
more than f um
40 days
uh city in blockade
we had a lot of um
again facts about war crimes inside
mariupol we understand it's not only war
crimes it is crimes against humanity but
because
now only in mario pal 90 percentage of
civilian infrastructure is destroyed we
have other uh
cities in ukraine in northern part of
ukraine in eastern part and ukraine as a
for example hercule when russian troops
again and again bombed civilian objects
hospitals kindergartens
schools near 1 000 educational
institutions destroyed it is civilian
infrastructure without militaries inside
a city
it's not cities or it's town town
baradian
it's a
town
without
militaries without military
infrastructure at all but it was bombed
and destroyed
thank you so much for
taking time out of your schedule i know
i know how busy you are but thank you so
much irina
thank you very much that you having us
here and we can possibility to speak
with your audience and i am very
appreciated for all great britain
citizens and especially
for your prime ministry who was
yesterday it's a really great support
for us and
you know we should stop it punish and
prevent if we don't do it now
you remember chichnya you remember
georgie you remember syria nothing now
ukraine what will be next nobody knows
that's why we should do it now very
professional but to to do what we should
to do
appreciate it
we're launching an exciting new program
later in the spring it's called the take
with the inimitable sophie ridge and
it'll be live every wednesday evening at
9 00 p.m and it's a chance for us to
take the political temperature midweek
and react to prime minister's questions
earlier in the day
sophie will be grilling government
ministers and opposition parties along
with backbenchers and others up and down
the country
but most importantly we want to get your
reaction we're searching for a regular
panel of sky news viewers to take part
in the program and share their opinions
on the big political issues of the week
if you'd like to be considered please
email the take with sophie ridge at sky
dot uk with just a couple of lines about
yourself and your politics and there's
more information online at news.sky.com
now as we've been discussing this
morning the reason the chancellor is in
such trouble over his family's tax and
residence arrangement
is how all this looks at a time when so
many people's finances are being
squeezed sometimes by decisions he
himself is taking
ad work benefits will rise by a little
over three percent tomorrow whilst
inflation is heading north of eight
percent that's a very significant cut in
income and living standards for some of
the uh those on the lowest incomes in
the country
in fact the joseph rowntree foundation
says it will be the greatest fall in the
value of basic rate of out-of-work
benefits in 50 years
joseph roundry foundation director helen
barnard joins me now
good morning ms barnard um
why do you say this is the biggest fall
uh in such a long
period what we've seen obviously is for
a decade we've had cuts and freezes to
benefits and actually for eight of the
last 10 years the benefits have been
losing value
so we're already at a historic low
now because although benefits go up
tomorrow they go up by so much less than
the cost of living is rising
it means that in terms of their value so
how much bread and milk you can buy in
the shops it is the biggest fall in
value since 1972 for 50 years
and obviously people are already very
often in quite desperate situations they
are struggling to afford
food and heating and basic hygiene
products
and now the government is imposing this
enormous cut
probably at the worst possible time
given how difficult things are out there
in the country
uh from your research what um
can you describe the real world impact
of this to some of the families that
you've talked to
well i mean we're seeing things like
pensioners riding the buses all day to
keep warm
we're seeing children who are using a
torch at night because even at age six
they know their parents can't afford to
turn the lights on all the time
we've heard from food banks who are
saying that please don't donate fresh
food because the people we're helping
can't afford to plug the fridge in let
alone cook food
there was a story the other day about a
young man a teenager fainting at a food
bank
because he hadn't eaten enough in the
run-up
and actually we're seeing this spread so
people who have been donating and
volunteering for years
are actually having to say at the end of
their shift have we got any left over
because i can't afford to eat properly
anymore
i don't know if you had the chance to
listen to um
the crime policing minister kit
malthouse when i spoke to him about what
45 minutes ago and asked him about this
and he said that
in essence the government had no choice
after
covered and the amount was spent there
the uncertainties for the public
finances
engendered by the conflict uh in ukraine
um
what's your answer to
that uh case
i think if you look at the spring
statement the chancellor spent about 18
billion pounds that's the money that he
decided he could afford to spend he
probably could have spent more and still
stayed within his rules but let's just
take the 18 billion
of that money about two-thirds went to
benefit people in the richest half of
the country
so he actually had the money the issue
is that the government is not
prioritizing using the money they have
to protect the poorest people who are
facing the greatest hardship
your report today is about people who
are dependent on benefits but um the
squeeze isn't just facing those people i
think
people in work are also facing uh some
drop in their living standards um what
what does uh your organization
uh think is going to happen to those in
work and what the what will be the
impact on them
of course many people at work also get
benefits to top up low earnings
so this squeeze on benefits actually
affects a lot of low-income workers as
well as people who can't work because
they are disabled or they're caring for
small children or they're caring for
adults so actually workers are going to
feel this and of course it's this kind
of irony that even where you have
something like raising the national
insurance threshold which helps some not
all but some low-income workers
people who are earning little enough
that they get topped up by benefit
system actually lose a lot of the
benefit of something like that because
their benefits get pulled away to make
up for the fact that they're keeping a
bit more of their income so actually i
mean low income workers are facing
incredibly difficult situations and you
know we know the majority of people in
poverty now are in working households
one of the problems is that too many
jobs are not just low paid but they're
insecure you know you don't know what
money you're getting one week to the
next you don't get sick pay
you don't get protection if something
goes wrong
and so it is people who are really
vulnerable in that situation when
they're working who are also now
struggling to afford you know the basic
essentials and having to rely on
charities or you know toothpaste and
toilet roll and you know it it's
humiliating for a lot of people you know
wonderful as it is that people are
helping
to know that even if you're working two
jobs you still can't afford to turn your
heating on or buy your child a pair of
shoes that fit them that's not a
situation anyone should be in
helen barnard thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you
that is it for this week's sophie ridge
on sunday
in a moment after the break we'll run
through today's interview and see what
we learned in the take
uh thank you for joining me on this uh
oneness uh one in
a time
one time return for a sunday morning
[Music]